as the pseudoscience of transgenderism
evolves by the day seemingly by the hour
one Munchausen by proxy mother has
offered a new category of evidence for
being born in the wrong body vegetable
preferences
that anxiety and would never sleep and
we couldn't figure out what the problem
was we took him to Specialists and
neurologists and he had brain scans
trying to figure out why he couldn't
sleep
then as he grew he got to sleeping but
his food choices were odd they were
always like green vegetables raw green
vegetables which you know kids most kids
don't like to eat those things
um and then the precocious puberty
um all of those things once we figured
out uh that he was transgender when he
came to us and told us that he was
transgender when we went back and
realized that the pattern of everything
that he had experienced as a child
including eating green vegetables
because that boosts testosterone were
just methods of his body trying to
become who he was meant to be
his brain does not match his physiology
the brain is part of physiology
your brain can't not match your
physiology because your brain is
physical and constitutes part of your
physiology this woman has no idea what
she's talking about obviously because
she thinks her daughter is a boy because
she ate vegetables
it isn't funny it's so absurd that one
is tempted to laugh until one remembers
that this lunatic has done her level
best to ruin her daughter's life I
mention this clip which is a public clip
this is a woman who not only did and
believes these things but willingly
admitted to it at a public forum in
Louisiana over a bill that would protect
kids from people like her I mentioned
this clip not just to make a point about
transgenderism but to make a point about
belief in general
lots of modern people consider
traditional religion to be superstitious
they think that Christianity in
particular is preposterous
that Christianity is unfit to be the
animating Spirit of our nation
Christians believe in an omnipotent God
and the Incarnation and the Redemption
how crazy is that
yeah
and modern liberals believe that eating
green vegetables means we ought to chop
a person up to make him look like a
grotesque caricature of the opposite sex
I'm not saying
that religion isn't mysterious
but if you think Christian civilization
is weird
just you wait until you experience
non-Christian civilization a Michael
knows this the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show
we've got a great clip out of the White
House as the World falls down around us
as we might be on the brink of World War
III Korean Jean-Pierre faces the
toughest question of all we'll get to
that in just a moment first though
which is transier would you say spinach
or Bud Light which is more likely to
make you a little bit light in the
loafers which is more likely to push you
toward the rainbow flag would it be
spinach would it be uh escarole would it
be broccoli rabe or would it be a can of
Bud Light Bud Light is sick of the jokes
Bud Light has had enough of the jokes
about them
and Anheuser-Busch is saying it was just
one can this is their new every day they
have a new response every day you get a
letter or a commercial about horses or
this or that so here's what Bud Light
has said now this is through their
distributor you say
this was one single can given to one
social media influencer it was not made
for production or sale to the general
public this can is not a formal campaign
or advertisement leave us alone leave
Britney alone and stop it in reality
they say the Bud Light can was can
posted by a social media influencer that
sparked all the conversation was
provided by an outside agency without
anheuser-busch's management awareness or
approval since that time the lack of
oversight and control over marketing
decisions has been addressed and a new
VP of Bud Light marketing has been
announced okay great so this is the
biggest walk back we've seen yet
certainly better than when Bud Light
doubled down on the campaign certainly
better than the letter from the CEO
where he basically just said I love the
military stop boycotting us certainly
better than the horses commercial better
even than the temporary suspension of
this VP of marketing
they're saying look this was obviously a
mistake they're insinuating this was
obviously a mistake I don't we did it
wasn't it wasn't even a campaign it
wasn't even it's not even what you think
it is just
okay
you're so close
say you're sorry
say you're sorry say it was the wrong
decision and say and this is the crucial
part
say that men and women are different
say that men can't really be women
say that you oppose transgender ideology
that is the only way to fix this
you're so close every day every three
days you inch a little bit closer to
doing that
which would probably work
but you don't ever quite get that you're
so cautious and
you think about life that by being
cautious and clever in your language
that you're going to be able to straddle
the fence here you're not your sales
numbers are just going to get worse and
worse and worse it's not like the sales
number is declined and then they've kind
of just stayed there that would be a
problem for Bud Light too they keep
declining
because there's no Middle Road on this
issue
to quote a certain speech from CPAC this
year that caused a lot of consternation
there is no conciliatory middle way on
the issue of transgenderism some issues
there there is a middle way this one
there isn't one
either men and women are different or
they're not different either women get
their own bathrooms or they don't get
their own bathrooms
you you
maybe could have avoided the issue had
you avoided the issue I'm not saying
that every company in America needs to
go send out a statement of metaphysics
and anthropology okay
but you inserted yourself into the issue
and you offended your whole customer
base and you said something that's
manifestly wrong and it's a it's a
urgent social issue that is having
harmful effects for lots and lots of
people really for everybody involved
especially for the people who've Fallen
prey to this confusion
so now you're in it
and the only way out is going to be
through
the only way out Bud Light you can do it
you say I'm sorry
we were wrong
transgenderism isn't real
come out and say it
we'll drink Bud Light again I drank like
three Bud Lights a year but I'll drink
Bud Light again if Bud Light came out
and said it
it would be better to me
than had Bud Light never waded into
these Waters in the first place if Bud
Light came out and said we're sorry this
was wrong transgenderism's fake men
can't really become women
I would buy more Bud Light than I did
before because that would send a message
to the rest of corporate America
which is that
if you come out and defend the truth and
Sanity and reason
we will have your back you will have an
audience base there it would encourage
other companies so do it Bud Light
do it I'll buy a case or two I don't
know I'll at least talk about it when
you want to talk to your friends you got
to check out Pure Talk
right now head on over to puretalk.com
Knowles we all know about the big
wireless cell companies out there they
lock you into these horrendous contracts
and then if you try to get out of them
early they tack on outrageous charges
which is why I love puretalk Wireless
where there are no hidden fees no
contacts and no hassle pure talk to U.S
customer service team has helped so many
people make the switch in as little as
10 minutes they were even able to keep
their own phone number I'm so glad that
I use Pure Talk frankly just the
us-based customer service team would be
enough for me but you get the same
networks that you're using right now you
can get unlimited talk text plenty of
data the price is much much lower it's
so simple it's so easy head on over to
puretalk.com enter promo code Knowles
Canada wlas to save 50 5-0 off your
first month that is puretalk.com promo
code knowlescano w l e s b like me use
Pure Talk Pure Talk is simply
smarter Wireless
speaking of middle of the road
we got all the Republican presidential
candidates we've got three presidential
candidates for the Democrat Party Joe
Biden running as the 2023 liberal
establishment finger in the wind
whichever way the progressives want to
go that's the way he goes you've got
Marianne Williamson who is the dark
psychic Force's new AG candidate in the
race and then you've got got RFK Jr and
RFK Jr is running as a Democrat
from the past here's what RFK Jr had to
say on immigration
he said Francisco orrapizza Perez Torres
has been arrested for the murder of five
people including a nine-year-old boy
Torres is a Mexican already deported
four times it is not anti-immigrant
bigotry to demand an immigration system
that keeps out criminals in fact letting
them in Stokes bigotry as president I
will enforce a secure border and I will
expand the kind of legal immigration
that made our country great
okay
that's a perfectly
reasonable position
if you're a Democrat from the 1960s
but that is not the position today
of modern Democrats or modern
Republicans
people want more than just stopping
illegal immigration
the Democrats want mass mass migration
the federal government came out
yesterday said
that we're looking at 10 000 border
crossers per day so that's what over
three and a half million people per year
in addition to the
million legal immigrants who come in
Democrats want they want even more than
that they want to flood the country with
foreign Nationals they think it redounds
to their political benefit the
Republicans
say no we don't we don't want any
illegal immigration a lot of Republicans
are now finally beginning to talk about
restricting legal immigration too and
then you look at public opinion surveys
the vast majority of people including
lots of Democrats want to drastically
reduce not only illegal but legal
immigration too according to a Harvard
Harris poll that I keep I keep bringing
up on the show because that poll unlike
a lot of polls on immigration asked
precise questions so it wasn't just the
sort of poll do you like immigrants or
are you a bigot it was a poll that got
into numbers
and they asked what is the ideal number
of immigrants per year people said
numbers like half a million
a half a million is very different from
what we're looking at right now
three million four million five million
who knows
there's there's there's no
1960s Democrat Lane in this race
got to pick a side and conservatives and
Republicans sometimes fall into the same
trap that Bobby Kennedy Jr is falling
into which is you think well let me just
rewind the clock 20 years let me just
rewind the clock in this case
50 or 60 years
and then we're just going to freeze time
there but that's not how time works
that's not how politics Works ideas have
consequences and power and they have a
movement and history has a movement and
so you can't just rewind the clock and
then go back to where you were with
exactly the same premises you're going
to end up in very likely the same place
that you are right now so we need to
think okay what's the purpose of
immigration
is the purpose of immigration to do
justice to the people around the world
or is the purpose of immigration to help
our country you're gonna have very
different immigration policies who sets
immigration policy is it some liberal
apparatchics who are unaccountable to
the people okay then you're going to get
millions and millions of immigrants
every year who sets immigration policy
the people well if it's the people then
you want to not only get rid of illegal
you want to drastically reduce legal as
well it is not the 1960s you can't
freeze time you can't freeze history
it's important for politicians to know
what time it is I applaud Bobby Kennedy
for trying to bring his party into a
saner place it's not there it's not
going there anytime soon so your options
are
where the modern Progressive Democrats
are or the Republicans and the
conservatives and we need them to be
clearer as well speaking of immigration
do you know how many
illegal aliens
are waiting to flood into our country in
about
six days
seven hundred thousand
there are 700 000 foreign Nationals in
Mexico right now who are waiting for
title 42 to expire on May 11th to flood
into our country
this is according to
well this is according even to the
federal government we're looking at the
the number of people that would
constitute the city of Boston or my own
city the city of Nashville waiting to
flood into the country
title 42. so that's okay you're gonna
get 700 000 then then you're gonna get
another what ten thousand per day where
does it end
where does it end it ends with
Democrats just replacing the American
people I know you're not allowed to say
that I don't know what the politically
correct term is because you the
Democrats told me you can't refer to
replacement Theory whatever replacement
theory is okay well what do you call it
when you intentionally flood hundreds of
thousands of people into the country and
and furthermore what is
the point of having a military is the
point of having a military so that we
can go invade Libya and so that we can
go and
fight a war in Ukraine and so that we
can go into Iraq and Syria or is the
point of having a military to protect
our country because if stopping 700 000
foreigners from invading our country is
not a good use of the military I don't
really know what is
speaking of law enforcement
meant to get to the story yesterday it's
the one that everyone on the left is
talking about that would be Jordan Neely
Jordan Neely was a homeless guy who was
arrested
40 plus times I think it was 44 times in
New York
for things like public lewdness for
assaulting a senior citizen so for
pretty serious stuff and then he was on
the subway he was behaving in a way that
according to eyewitnesses was hostile
and erratic and so someone intervened to
protect the people on the subway
a lot of people get hurt on the subway
in the New York City subway many many
times and I've seen people acting
violent I've seen people threatening
people
increasingly in New York you're seeing
physically harming others and New York
doesn't do anything about it
the cops are largely told to stand down
and then sometimes when the cops do
arrest people the DA's that the Soros
funded prosecutors let them off the hook
so you you take your life in your hands
now in certain parts of New York in
certain parts of the subway system so
what happened a few guys go in they
subdue the guy but Jordan nearly dies in
the process
what does AOC say AOC says Jordan Neely
was murdered
but because Jordan was houseless and
crying for food in a time when the city
is Raising rents and stripping services
to militarize itself while many in power
demonize the poor the murderer gets
protected with passive headlines and no
charges it's disgusting I don't want to
sound callous in any way here
homeless people in New York do not want
for food
that is not a thing I am very
sympathetic to the plight of homeless
people I think that what we have done
with regard to homeless policy is is
awful it's a complete abdication of Duty
it's the fault especially of the left
but of the right as well it's the fault
of an idea that we in a political
Community I have no obligation to our
fellow citizens and the idea that we
have no right to interfere with the uh
behavior of fellow citizens even when
those fellow citizens are mentally ill
or addicted to drugs
the conservatives sometimes have said
well you know they'll figure it out
and that's the worst version of
conservatives but the left for a very
long time has said well you have no
right to stop a man from doing drugs you
have no right to involuntarily commit a
mentally ill man you have homeless
people have the right to live on the
street that's no right that's a that's a
way to die that's a way to to be killed
in an altercation that's a way to dive a
drug overdose it's a way to die of
exposure
so I am totally sympathetic but all of
that is prefaced to say
if you are a homeless person in New York
you will be offered 10 000 sandwiches a
day
and what happens is when you offer
homeless people sandwiches in New York
sometimes
they'll say okay thanks and you go you
get them a sandwich maybe you chat a
little bit a lot of the time they'll
they won't want it because what they
really want is money for drugs what they
really want is
money for whatever else they don't
actually want the food so aoc's saying
this he was a man he was crying out for
a loaf of bread but that's of course not
not what happened if you've been
arrested 44 times don't you think
the time might come to say okay buddy
we're not going to let you out this time
because you can't take care of yourself
and so you don't have the ability to
exercise your Liberty and we're going to
get you the help that you need but no
that doesn't happen
and so when there's not a regular
authoritative trained Force to help in
these matters people are going to
protect themselves or they're not and
some senior citizens going to get
assaulted again
or they're not and someone's going to
get stabbed on the subway
but then these guys come in
and they take care of the this threat
and then the guy sadly dies and now
we've got the next George Floyd riots
the only thing that that surprised me
about this story is
it's a little bit early
wouldn't you say it's a little bit early
it's only May of 2023 the election's not
until November of 2024.
so the libs are going to try to create a
new George Floyd situation
and they're going to impel protests and
riots
and they're going to try to intimidate
Republicans
with their shock troop activists on the
ground
and they're going to try to burn
buildings down they're going to try to
threaten businesses and they're going to
try to do all the same stuff that they
always do because we're headed into a
presidential election year
just seems a little early can you if
they're pulling this kind of stuff now
if AOC is pulling this game now can you
imagine can you imagine
what it's going to look like in a Year
by the way the autopsy of the LA showed
no fracture to his hyoid bone which can
doesn't always but it can indicate
homicide by strangulation so they're
going to have more tests to reveal how
he died but he it's it is Rule to
homicide now they are going to have to
prosecute these guys because the mob
which doesn't care for truth demands it
if you
along with tens of millions of people
watched Netflix's hit show making a
murderer then you are going to love
daily wire Plus's new exclusive 10 part
series with Candace convicting a
murderer coming this summer whether it's
exposing black lives matter or certain
fallacies in the healthcare industry
regarding covid Candace is unafraid to
challenge The Narrative she'll find the
truth wherever it leads when Candace
found out that key facts may have been
omitted in Netflix's series she set out
to uncover the truth behind the
notorious Stephen Avery case and the end
result which is coming soon is a series
called convicting a murderer
you will not want to miss it right now
there has never been a better time to
become a daily wire plus member sign up
now for convicting a murderer you will
receive an early bird discount of 35 off
your daily wire Plus Membership don't
wait until the series comes out this
summer because this deal won't last long
you will also get all of the other
premium content from daily wire plus
including the greatest lie ever sold
what is a woman and Dr Jordan B Peterson
series on the book of Exodus join now at
dailywire.com subscribe to become a
member and see the truth when it finally
comes out my favorite comment yesterday
is from games with a jump who says
as a white man living in Texas who
recently came out as a black woman
living in California I could not be
happier congratulations I too will be
planning that transition if and when the
official reparations program goes into
effect and I might also identify as a
twin
and maybe that 1.2 million maybe that
can become 2.4 million
speaking of the police
the Nashville PD is continuing to
Stonewall on the manifesto of the trans
identifying shooter who shot up a
Christian Elementary School
I have been defending the Nashville PD
in part because of the heroic actions of
the officers but in part because I know
that this is a politically tough case
for them and I know that they've got the
FBI breathing down their necks even
though the FBI the Memphis field office
told the daily wire in the days after
the shooting that the FBI really has no
jurisdiction here there's no evidence
that the FBI should be involved but then
all of a sudden we find out the FBI is
involved and there are all of these
issues about releasing the manifesto for
virtually every other one of these
shootings where there is a Manifesto we
get to read the manifesto we especially
get to read the manifesto if it's an
angry straight white guy who is in any
way right-wing
but in this case
where
all signs seem to point to
transgenderism being at the ideological
factor in the shooting here
we we don't get the manifesto
so what are they saying they say due to
pending litigation filed this week the
Metropolitan Nashville police department
has been advised by Council to hold and
Advance the release of Records related
to the shooting at the Covenant School
for pending orders or direction of the
Court
okay
why do they have to hold it what's the
litigation the litigation is from the
Tennessee Firearms Association
trying to get the manifesto out
so they're saying the the Tennessee
Firearms Association asserts that the
police wrongly denied public records
requests and so they want to get the
manifesto out and the national PD is
trying not to release the manifesto and
then they now their their excuse now as
to why they won't release the manifesto
is that there's pending litigation about
why they won't release the manifesto so
this is obviously a purely political
matter and the the political leadership
that is preventing the Nashville PD from
doing the right thing should be ashamed
of itself and we should see the
manifesto period
okay
now
two stories I really want to get to from
the the federal government itself one is
you know they're always going after the
libs are always going after Clarence
Thomas hey Clarence Thomas they're
saying Clarence Thomas has bought and
paid for he's bribed he went on a fancy
vacation with some Republican guy and
therefore he has to quit the Supreme
Court they say oh Clarence Thomas he he
knows
people in politics and this is a
terrible conflict of interest okay well
how about this this is a story broken by
the daily wire and Luke rosiak liberal
Supreme Court Justice
Sonia Sotomayor took three million
dollars from penguin random house or
book publisher and she refused to recuse
herself from cases involving that
publisher
say you know a conservative donor took
Clarence Thomas on a on a vacation to
his Woodland Resort
I don't know what's the what's the value
of that I don't know probably not a ton
of money but whatever it is you know is
it three million dollars
and then has Thomas been dealing with
litigation involving that donor
and not recused himself and no of course
it's always whatever the libs accused
the conservatives of they did it better
now no one cares no one cares about the
hypocrisy so that's not going to affect
anything at all it's just good to have
this in our quiver this is a really
great story great job on Luke for for
uncovering this uh the next time they go
after Clarence Thomas which will
probably be Monday this is the great
story to pull out and defuse that and
speaking of the libs not being able to
answer questions
Corrine Jean-Pierre
not known as the greatest White House
Press Secretary in history we're on the
brink potentially of World War III
you've got a drone attack on the Kremlin
to kill Vladimir Putin you're seeing the
US involvement in Ukraine has ramped up
you're seeing the economy collapsing
you're seeing runs on banks you're
seeing 700 000 migrants at the border
Biden's got a lot to answer for but he
can't even answer the basic questions
Joe Biden won't even answer how many
grandchildren he has he is very cruelly
refused to acknowledge his seventh
grandchild because she was born out of
wedlock and she's Hunter Biden's
daughter so we finally had a reporter
ask Kareen Jean-Pierre about this here's
what the White House said
and how come they haven't acknowledged
the seventh grandchild I'm not going to
speak to that from here
why not go ahead
I'm not going to speak to that from here
ask this question every day I know it
seems like a trivial point and in the
grand scheme of
politics I suppose
it's not the most important issue but
it's just so nasty what Biden's doing
it's just so cruel what this guy has
done
imagine you're this little girl and your
grandfather is the president of the
United States and he refuses to
acknowledge you and he's a forgetful guy
so when people do remind him he just
refuses to acknowledge his imagine
growing up like that
being told not only does your father not
want you and your father's a complete
degenerate Hunter Biden but that your
grandfather who's supposed to be the
good guy who's the president of the
United States something you could be
really proud of even though you've got a
kind of a difficult background and then
this guy says I want nothing to do with
you I don't even acknowledge Your
Existence granddaughter that's such a
cruel ugly thing and it really Cuts
against the nice guy Good Old Uncle Joe
give me an ice cream cone to Lake Jack
I'm a normal guy come on I'm likable
good old Joe it really Cuts against that
reputation it's a nasty nasty thing to
do I I hope they hold his feet to the
fire and I hope that they force Biden to
do the right thing
absolutely
now putting political pressure on the
White House putting political pressure
on Supreme Court Justice Sonia Sotomayor
and really great news coming out of St
Louis looks like a George Soros funded
prosecutor Kim Gardner is going to have
to step down as St Louis circuit
attorney why because she engaged in one
too many obviously politically motivated
prosecutions and so there's a lot of
pressure on her right now to step down
she is insisting that she's being
targeted
she is insisting that all of this
political pressure it's forcing her not
to be able to do her job as a prosecutor
and it's totally unjust but the fact is
if she had the political Capital to
survive she would but she hasn't because
she's bad at her job she's not serving
the people that she's supposed to serve
and the Republicans finally have enough
force that we can get her out of it
great stuff I love it I know that the
squishes are going to hate this they're
going to say we shouldn't be
politicizing the justice department and
prosecutions yes we should we need to
wield all of the political power that we
possibly can right now because the libs
control everything No More Mr Nice Guy
we gotta Force these prosecutors out of
office we've got to tax the university
endowments we've got to to beef up
defamation law so we can go after the
liberal media we've got to beef up
antitrust so we can go after big Tech we
need to do everything it's got to be a
full-up we've got to build our own
economy we've got to build our own
institutions we got a boycott Bud Light
I don't want to hear about listen I
don't want my companies to be involved
in politics at all I just well the libs
are going to force that so as Oren
McIntyre has put it very well he says
the party that wants to win is always
going to beat the party that wants to be
left alone so if you've got the left in
this country forcing the corporations to
adopt their insane ideas and then you've
got the right saying I just don't I
don't want any kind of politics then the
corporations are just inevitably going
to move to the left that's why this boy
but but light boycott is so great no
we've got to go further we've got to
stop suffering from this failure of
imagination we've got to say hey Bud
Light staying out of politics that's no
longer good enough come out and say
transgenderism is fake say you're sorry
for adopting it
insinuate at the very least that it's
bad for society especially bad for the
kids who are being chopped up by
Munchausen by proxy mothers who think
the green vegetables turn you trans cut
it out enough No More Mr Nice Guy
we need to be Mr good guy we need to be
Mr just guy we need to be Mr ordered
Society guy
we shouldn't just be nice and allow very
bad people and ideas to ruin our country
now we're going to turn to some very
good people the very good people in
our mailbag this mailbag is sponsored by
pure talk at puretalk.com select to plan
enter code Knowles to get 50 off your
first month they gave me a telephone on
set today I kind of like the idea can I
ring ring ring give me the first
voicemail
hey Michael this is Iowa conservative
I'm 25 years old and my wife is 24. we
have uh three kids four and under
my wife is currently a stay-at-home mom
and my question to you is is uh I
currently work from home I make 85 to 95
a year I'm you know climbing the ladder
getting promotions and everything but if
I do take the next promotion
um and keep on claiming this ladder it
will require overnight not a lot of
overnights maybe like once a month or
once every other month but it's still
time away from the home and from the
family overall it's obviously going to
be more money better job better pay uh
everything like that or do I stay at
home working from home for a few years
and I'm around for my child's younger
years what's your take on this
I need one extra piece of information
which is are you saying that the
difference is right now you're working
from home 100 of the time but if you get
the new job you're going to be working
from home some of the time but you're
also going to be working overnights
somewhere else some of the time or is it
you're working from home now and
the new job would require you in the
office all the time and sometimes you're
there overnight too
the reason that matters is it's just a
totally different lifestyle
between working from home and not
working from home if it were me
you know what I would do I would take
the job I work a lot of overnights I
travel around the country I'm traveling
right now and I I don't love to do it I
try to minimize it
but if you're saying it's going to be
one or two nights a month and that's
going to give you a substantially higher
salary and more importantly put you on a
path to make more money and have a have
a bigger job down the line
yeah I would say that's a no-brainer to
me
because you're making decent money
you're making 85 90 grand a year that's
good money but
for kids what five kids six kids I don't
know how many kids you're gonna get I
mean it seems like you're on the right
track so that that money can go away
pretty quickly especially now that under
Joe Biden's inflation policies a cup of
coffee costs like 72 dollars so so I
would probably do that the only argument
against it I would say because I'm also
pretty traditional in that I like the
idea that man goes out brings home the
bacon you know he doesn't need to be
home all day and I think sweet little at
least we get sick of it if I were home
all day
but
the the question is
if we're talking about okay this this
new job is you're really at the office
all the time and then in addition to
that overnight as well
what is the additional cost going to be
to you for child care maybe you need
someone to help out with the kids during
the daytime hours every now and again
maybe you consider that maybe you
consider
how
maybe you just consider how important
your career is to you if you were making
no money I'd say go get a real job come
on but you're making decent money so
I would
I would lean toward take the job but
it's not a science it's not a totally
even cut thing you've got to analyze all
of the particulars next one
hi Michael
big fan of the show really appreciate
all that you do
so I just finished with a nice vegan
propaganda documentary and it led me to
an interesting thought that I think you
might find pretty interesting as well
in Genesis
it talks about before the fall of Man
how
there was no death in the garden
now if there was no death in the garden
I'm assuming that would also mean
animals and since animals need to die in
order to be eaten
would that mean that Adam and Eve were
vegans
look forward to your thoughts thanks
[Music]
I don't see why they'd have to be vegans
I guess they were probably vegetarians
that is my read on the garden
because you don't really see anyone
eating meat until after the flood
which doesn't and
suggest that it's wrong to eat meat just
a fact of where we are in history now
but yeah in the Garden of Eden I assumed
they were vegetarians but why can't they
get the milk out there's no death but
you probably get like a little milk out
of the cow right probably get cheese you
probably get eggs
now there's no defense of veganism
there's zero defense there's some days
one can be vegetarian Fridays good day
not to eat meat
maybe eat some fish or something but no
that's true then after the flood we get
meat and now we're making up for lost
time with good ranchers okay next one
hello Michael otherwise Nostradamus this
is Holly McLean username is Mommy answer
lady and I have a question that you can
settle among your nulls at alls on
Facebook the question has arisen of
whether you would prefer your newly
forming cult to go by nulsa dolls or
creme de La Creme
The Dilemma is that you refer to all
those who are members of The Daily wire
and listen to the members block of your
show as creme de La Creme but there are
some who are joining the cult who are
not members of daily wire so do you wish
your loyal followers to be called
Knowles adults meaning all who want to
enter the cult whether DW to subscribers
or not or creme de La Creme meaning only
those who are members of daily wire and
can hear the members block and if the
latter should we change the name of the
Facebook group from Knowles adults to
creme de La Creme
love the show Michael knows it all's for
life
thank you very much very important
question uh
I guess if we're talking about my cult
I would moderate I would model it after
that Nexium cult remember the Nexium one
that was in the news like four or five
years ago because the Nexium cult it was
a cult but then there was a cult within
a cult so it was Nexium and then I
forget what the the inner one was and
Nexium was just broadly kind of weird
and then the intercult was Dungeons and
whips and chains and sex stuff so no I'm
not which I'm not suggesting or
encouraging occur in this case but I
mention it because
perhaps the
broader category you know the cult that
kind of pulls people in that could be
the Knowles at alls and then that inner
circle without the weird sex stuff could
be the the claimed a lot of time or vice
versa I don't know that's not up to me
okay I don't
take on the day-to-day manage your real
responsibilities of the cult
I simply want to be the the guru you
know like that Indian guy in the midwest
or but and I and I cannot stress this
enough
without the weird sex stuff but thank
you I'm I'm very excited to know what
you decide upon for this important
matter okay next one
hi Michael I didn't grow up religious at
all
five and I want to explore religion but
I'm finding it hard every time I take a
step into religion I get so overwhelmed
and realize that there's so much that I
don't know or that I don't understand I
only know two people who say that they
have a relationship with God and both of
them have different views and beliefs do
you have any advice for me on how to
stop feeling so overwhelmed and any tips
on how to go from a firm atheist to
believing in God also thank you for the
work you do and I think listening to you
has helped me realize that religion
should be an important part of society
wonderful I'm so pleased to hear all of
that
the advice I give people now is not the
advice that I took exactly but I'll just
give it to you because I I've heard it
is helpful for a lot of people is just
start by praying I especially love to
pray the rosary I think the rosary is a
wonderful prayer
um so you could you could begin with
that how did it work for me though I was
in a similar situation from you it's sad
I mean you were truly raised without any
religion I was raised with some religion
but I I fell away from it at age 13. and
so here's what I would do if it were me
no I think probably for most people
praying is that that's probably the
smarter like quicker way to do it I took
a very long time here I first became
convinced that God exists and I was
convinced that God exists by the many
arguments for God's existence Thomas
Aquinas is five ways the ontological
argument there are all sorts of
arguments for the existence of God the
the arguments for the existence of God I
think are quite persuasive I've never
seen any good argument against the
existence of God even including the
problem of pain The Odyssey which is
which is
probably the nearest thing to an
argument against God okay so God exists
then the question is who is God what is
God like
and of the theistic religions
you've got
Judaism Christianity and Islam
there are these sort of manichaean
dualist religions of a good force and an
evil force but the arguments for God
don't really lend themselves to that
that's just nonsense so okay you got
Judaism Christianity and Islam seems
like a good place to start might be to
read the Bible or attend church where
the Bible is read liturgically and
within the tradition but you go through
that and then you say okay God exists
God is like the god of the Bible now
you've got to deal with the person of
Christ is Christ who he says he is
uh I confronted that problem I don't
know about maybe 23 years old or
something and I concluded yes he is uh
C.S Lewis writes beautifully about this
in a modern way for Mere Christianity
was a book that was important when I was
reverting and so I say okay yes Jesus is
who he says he is
and
then you have to confront okay well what
is his church like is his church
what the Catholic Church says it is is
this church like
any of the Protestant denominations say
it is is what's the church like and I I
reverted greatly under the influence of
a lot of protestant theologians and
speakers so you know I and writer like
C.S Lewis
um so obviously you know have a great
deal of respect for our Protestant
friends but I ultimately concluded that
the church is what the church says she
is that the Catholic church is real and
so I reverted to that that was a process
that took me like
five or six years
no I'm sorry it took me for that was
from the moment I started to think about
it again really it was a process that
took me about 10 years if you started
age 13. so probably the faster way is to
just pray to God and ask for Grace but
if you want the process that did work
for me and is this similar to the
situation that you're in that's what I
would do okay we've got a lot of written
mailbag got to get to it some really
really good spicy questions this week
and then it's fake headline Friday I
need your help
to analyze the headlines here and figure
out the fake one so that I can beat
Mr Davies the the show continues now
dailywire.com Knowles use promo code
Knowles get two months free on all
annual plans see you there
[Music]
foreign